can you Ace this basic test  many people struggle with squares of  negative numbers the key is to evaluate  in the order of groupings exponents and  then multiplications  the first problem translates to the  square of negative three which is  negative three times negative three and  that's equal to 9.  the next problem is the opposite of 3  squared three times three is nine so the  opposite is negative nine  next since x equals negative 3 we want  the square of negative three  this has the same answer as the first  question which is nine  the last question is the opposite of the  square of negative three this is the  opposite of nine which is equal to  negative nine  here's a quick review of the answers  how many did you get correct